francis ce soir j'aimerais vraiment que
tu me donnes ta version qu'est ce qui
s'est passé mais on met sa voix tout est
sur les images donc quoi donc ils
viennent te voir
et comment est est ce que tu es ce que
tu fais ce que tu as déjà fait le récit
est ce que ta mine patata un nom à l'un
des becs non non non aucun coup n'a été
donnée tout d'abord des coûts n'a été
donnée j'ai tous les témoignages pour
chat j'ai toutes les preuves pour ça
mais les preuves à 100 sur l'image de
toute façon on voit bien je suis
toujours un mètre cinquante de gaye film
il se prend un peu les pieds dans le
stand mais il tigresse bien droit et le
gars me retiens l'autre c'est pas moi
qui le touche à c'est lui qui
s'agrippent qui s'agrippent à moi par
deux fois malgré ma tendinite bon peu
importe mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que bien évidemment j'ai donné aucun
coup alors je te raconte histoire mais
je suis au stand de premières
démocraties inquiète instant de très
intéressant il y avait là un auteur que
je voulais rencontrer jean molina qui a
écrit un très beau livre qui s'appelle
peut-on bâtir la démocratie on discutait
tranquillement ensemble et la lega il
arrive même pas bonjour rien il met le
micro données et là j'ai compris
là j'ai vu ils m'ont mis devant mener
j'ai vu ces quotidiens
donc là que j'ai dis quoi ils vont
essayer de piéger bien sûr là je sais
pourquoi ils sont là je sais ce qu'ils
vont faire de ces images alors là le
problème c'est que dans ces cas là tu
vois c'est bâbord tribord qu'est ce que
je fais est ce que je le dégage tout de
suite je lui dis je veux pas parler avec
toi je sais qu'il va surfer là dessus
qui va essayer de me piéger là dessus
que le mec veut tu vas battre filmé par
titre
c'est des méthodes de dix en utilisent
emplois pour mettre les gens en
difficulté alors que voilà et donc je me
dis francis ne fais pas de procès
d'intention à ce garçon il n'a pas de
très bonne manière il a pas dit bonjour
et payet s'est pas excusé de déranger
les 2,5 de s'immiscer dans la
conversation mais voilà écoute
la question qui va se poser et là il
fait comme ils font d'habitude il fait
semblant de me poser une question pour
me mettre à l'aise tu vois cccc des
méthodes bien connues ça on met la
pression au début pour te faire des voix
là et après leurs attaques et après tu
as parlé sur marie bigard voilà donc moi
je commençais ne va pas je commence par
répondre à sa question qui était
intéressante
et tout d'un coup ça n'a rien à voir
avec le sujet commence à me parler de
jean marie dans les thèmes que je peux
pas accepter donc qu'est ce que je fais
à ce moment là de manière très calme
avec un peu d'autorité
parce que ça nous met en colère mais
quand même je reste encore dans comment
dire dans une forme de douceur quand
même de gentillesse je lui dis monsieur
maintenant si ça te rend cette tournure
je ne désire plus parler avec vous vous
devez brancher votre caméra et tu sais
que normalement quand tu dis juste
l'image de quelqu'un faut l'autorisation
de diffusion et ça donc on demande aux
gens devant la caméra de dire
j'autorise qu'on utilise mon image donc
moi je fais le contraire je dis je
n'autorise pas que usage de mon image et
balade donc c'est pour ne pas donner
l'autorisation de diffusion donc c'est
formidable là j'ai la preuve que je n'ai
pas donné et dans la demi-heure qui a
suivi j'ai appelé d'ailleurs le
diffuseur et la maison de production
pour dire je vous confirme que je ne
vous donne pas l'autorisation de
diffusion et à ce moment là je vois
qu'il continue à filmer
donc je me lève et je n'ai qu'une seule
idée en tête c'est il efface interview
dont ils t'ont fait croire qu'il a
effacé l'interview oui en plus j'ai la
preuve de sa stature ça ils l'ont dit
ils me disent on fait croire crise en
jean et en plus et ça c'est des
journalistes non mes excuses après ils
ont eu peur en s'offrant 6h de poids
pour que tu lises ont ils ont été un peu
échaudé par ils sont dire je vais me
prendre je vais pas leur dire quelque
chose
ils ont tous simuler y compris la peur
parce qu'il n'y avait aucune raison
d'avoir peur puisque je n'ai pas levé la
main sur eux donc tout ça et d'ailleurs
ça se voit dans les images c'est
extraordinaire ça se voit dans les
images ça se voit dans les images c'est
à dire que le gars il dit à un moment
donné quand il fait semblant d'effacer
l'image tout le monde et calmer tout le
monde est tranquille et il dit mon
équipe n'est plus en sécurité
il se fout de la gueule des gens ces
gens là